Welcome to a deep dive into Ereza Shakazemi's spiritual ethos, where we hear the mandate sent with the new governor of Egypt in its entirety, delivering a warning about his own soul before it names a single duty of state.
A man who cannot govern his own soul cannot justly govern a province.
Yeah, just, I mean, think about the sheer gravity of that opening reality for a second.
It is massive.
Right.
Imagine you are the one receiving this mandate.
You are about to take over a territory that is
frankly, actively fracturing.
Totally.
There is severe unrest, factions are plotting, the borders are tense, and the treasury is just precarious.
Yeah, the stakes literally could not be higher for you.
Exactly.
Power, especially in a highly volatile region, is a wager.
It acts as an incredible accelerant.
It really does.
It tempts everyone who holds it to completely abandon their internal governance in favor of external control.
When a crisis is unfolding right outside your window, the inward kingdom is almost always the very first thing abandoned.
You want to secure the perimeter, not your own psyche.
That is the natural human reflex, isn't it?
Oh, absolutely.
If someone hands you the keys to a collapsing province tomorrow, what is the first thing you ask for?
The ledgers, probably.
Yeah, you probably ask for the ledgers, the troop movements, and the emergency powers.
The list you demand is purely material.
You want an army to enforce your will.
You want an overflowing public treasury to fund your administration, or at the very least, a heavy seal of office to legitimize your decrees so people listen when you speak.
Which makes sense on paper.
It does, but the imam
Peace be upon him, hands the new governor of Egypt absolutely none of these things initially.
Nothing at all.
No.
Instead, the longest and most comprehensive letter he ever wrote focuses its entire opening breath on the one territory a governor can lose completely unnoticed.
Which is his own soul.
His own soul.
Which is such a terrifying concept if you really sit with it.
Really is.
Because a lost army is obvious to everyone.
A depleted treasury is mathematically obvious.
You can just look at the spreadsheet.
Exactly, but a lost
soul.
A ruler can lose his internal compass and continue issuing decrees, collecting taxes, commanding troops, and sitting on a throne for years before the external rot becomes visible to the world at large.
Yeah, the decay of the state always lags behind the decay of the ruler's character.
Always.
By the time the institutions start crumbling, the internal architecture of the leader has been in ruins for a long time.
And this brings us to the core genius of the text you and I are unpacking today.
It takes the cosmic vision of a god beyond number, a god of infinite majesty, and brings it straight down to the wooden desk of a working administrator.
Just right there on the desk.
Right there.
It flatly refuses to treat theology as something you quietly ponder in a monastery on the weekends and stake
craft as something you do in the capital from Monday to Friday.
Those aren't two separate things here.
No, the mandate treats the running in Egypt and the saving of the governor's soul not as two different jobs, but as the exact same task.
The exact same task.
Every single practical instruction in this document
who to hire, how to tax, when to forgive, how to manage the agricultural runoff is anchored directly back to a fundamental claim about God and the self.
So, I mean, the inner front is the true battlefield.
It is.
And it is a relentlessly difficult front because, as the text suggests, the soul left to itself leans downward.
Gravity just pulls it.
Requires an immense, conscious, agonizing effort to elevate it.
requires what the mandate frames as divine mercy.
If you don't actively fight gravity, you fall.
You are hitting on a very specific view of human nature that this mandate relies upon.
Okay, unpack that.
Well, the imam tells the governor to curb his passions before he even mentions the word Egypt.
Before he even brings up the job.
Exactly.
He does this by referencing the profound confession made by Joseph in English, the soul incites to evil unless God bestows mercy.
The inner front is the hardest possible war for any leader to fight because the enemy wears the governor's own face.
Brutal realization.
It is.
Imagine fighting a war where the saboteur is your own desire, your own whim, your own caprice.
If you lose that fight internally, your office simply becomes a weapon against the very people you were commissioned to protect.
I don't buy that yet.
Yeah, let's really stress test this.
If power is a trust answerable to God,
What actually constrains a ruler who has simply stopped believing that?
Okay, fair question.
Or a ruler who is having a crisis of faith.
If you are running a state and your borders are collapsing, telling a governor to go reflect on his soul sounds like a dereliction of duty.
It sounds passive.
Right.
Isn't this just private piety?
Private piety remains completely silent on how to actually manage taxes, supply chains, and armies in the real world.
It is the most natural temptation in the world to separate personal piety from public administration.
We do it all.
We are deeply conditioned by modern political thought to view governance as a machine that operates independently of the operator's spiritual state.
We just want the machine to work.
Exactly.
We think that as long as the laws are good, it doesn't matter if the governor is spiritually bankrupt.
But I want to steel man your challenge.
Please do.
You are right that if this were just a command to just be a good person in your heart, it would be absolutely useless against the machinery of state violence.
It wouldn't do anything.
But the mandate corrects this assumption brilliantly.
It proves that every external order is inextricably anchored back to the soul.
So it's not just abstract.
Not at all.
The text does not leave the constraints abstract.
The imam instantly provides a rigid legal framework that dissolves the predatory instincts of a ruler, regardless of how they might be feeling on any given Tuesday.
Okay, how so?
Walk me through how a philosophical or spiritual classification actually solves the brutal mechanics of power.
By entirely eliminating the category of prey.
Prey.
Yeah, think about how empires usually classify people.
You have citizens, non-citizens, useful classes, expendable classes.
They rank everyone based on utility.
Precisely.
The mandate instructs the governor that the subjects living in Egypt are of only two kinds.
They are either your brother in religion or your equal in creation.
That is incredibly comprehensive.
It covers every single human being.
By establishing this absolute binary, the ruler is left with no third category.
So there is no outgroup.
None.
There is no subhuman class.
There is no acceptable collateral damage.
There is no alien group outside the circle of kinship that can be squeezed or exploited for the state's benefit.
Because they are either family or they are an equal.
Exactly.
You cannot treat a brother or an equal as fodder for your political ambitions.
So the private piety is immediately translated into a public structural constraint on how human bodies are legally categorized and treated by the state.
That completely shifts the lens.
It really does.
The inner disposition becomes the absolute prerequisite for seeing the population accurately.
Yes.
If you view a demographic as a problem to be solved or as prey to be consumed, your administration will inevitably become a hunting ground.
It's unavoidable.
But if you view them as kin or equals,
Your administration is forced to become a protective shelter.
Exactly.
But here is the practical friction, though.
What's that?
How does a ruler maintain that perspective?
Oh, that's the real test.
Right.
Because the sheer weight of authority, the fact that thousands of people stand up when you enter a room constantly whispers that you are, in fact, superior to those you govern.
This is where we need to look at the first of our three governing analogies.
The ladder of authority.
To combat that constant whisper of superiority, the imam constructs a vivid vertical reality for the governor to hold in his mind.
A vertical reality.
Yeah, picture an endless ladder.
Okay, I'm picturing it.
Every single rung of authority is answerable to the one directly above it.
So there's always someone higher.
Always.
The governor is above the people, yes, absolutely.
But the appointer is above the governor and God is above the appointer.
So it just keeps going up.
It does.
To forget the top of the ladder is to imagine you are standing on the solid ground of your own independent supremacy when in reality you are suspended in midair.
Suspended in midair.
That is a terrifying physical image for anyone holding office.
It's meant to be.
It strips away the illusion of absolute autonomy that power gives you.
aren't the owner of the house.
No, you're not.
Or merely a steward and the property belongs to someone else who is going to return and ask for an audit.
The reckoning is unavoidable.
And that reckoning addresses the specific psychological diagnosis of pride.
Pride is the root issue here, isn't it?
Is the absolute core issue.
In this framework, we have to understand that pride is not just a character flaw.
It's not just arrogance.
No, it's not a minor vice, like being a bit messy or occasionally rude.
Pride is a literal war declared against God.
A war.
It is a rival claim to greatness.
The new governor is explicitly warned not to say to himself, I have been given authority, so I command and am obeyed.
Because that sought alone is dangerous.
That specific sentence, that specific internal monologue is the seed of all political corruption.
It just poisons the well immediately.
It weakens the religion and draws misfortune near because it intoxicates the ruler.
It is the intoxication of agency.
That's a great way to put it.
Think about it from the perspective of
someone who has just taken office.
When people leap to obey your commands, when your signature moves millions of dollars or mobilizes thousands of troops, you begin to hallucinate.
You lose touch with reality.
You begin to believe you are the actual source of power rather than just a temporary conduit for it.
Exactly.
But what is the actual prescription for that kind of pride?
Because history shows us that suppression rarely works.
It almost never works.
If you just try to push the ego down through sheer willpower, it usually just mutates and returns in much more insidious, passive-aggressive ways.
You are entirely right that suppression doesn't work.
The cure provided here is not suppression.
What is it then?
It is a radical recalibration of vision.
Recalibration.
Yes, the cure for feeling large is forcing yourself to look at something genuinely infinitely large.
Just looking at the scale of things.
Right.
The mandate tells the governor that if his newfound
authority breeds vanity or a sense of grandeur, he must immediately look at the greatness of God's dominion above him and realize his own profound, almost comical limitations.
Zooming all the way out.
The governor is reminded that he cannot even command a single heartbeat in his own chest.
That is such a striking point.
It is.
His own pulse operates completely outside his jurisdiction.
How can a man whose own internal organs do not take his orders claim absolute sovereignty over a massive nature?
It's absurd when you frame it like that.
It restores what the imam calls good sense.
Pride is diagnosed here as a lapse in basic rationality.
And like a delusion.
Exactly, a break from reality long before it is judged as a moral failure.
It is an invitation to awe.
Yes.
And awe might be the only natural antidote to arrogance.
When you truly perceive the staggering scale of the cosmos,
your own temporary political appointment shrinks back to its proper fragile size.
It really puts things in perspective.
This sets the foundation perfectly.
The governor's soul is theoretically in check.
For the moment, yes.
But let's move from the internal state to the messy external reality of running a province.
A ruler doesn't govern in a vacuum.
No, they don't.
He is immediately surrounded by people clamoring for access.
The company a ruler keeps
dictates the information he receives, which dictates the decisions he makes.
The gatekeepers are everything.
So how does the mandate navigate the treacherous politics of access?
It navigates it by entirely upending the conventional wisdom of statecraft.
Upending it how?
Well, the imam gives a highly counterintuitive instruction regarding whose contentment the ruler should prioritize.
Okay.
He draws a razor sharp line between the common folk and the elite.
Two very distinct groups.
Very distinct.
Now, a ruler's natural survival instinct is to court the elite.
Of course.
The wealthy merchants, the influential families, the powerful military leaders, because they are incredibly useful and they are positioned right next to the levers of the state.
They have the money and the influence.
Exactly.
The mandate says to aggressively ignore the demands of the elite and focus completely on the contentment of the common folk.
Why on earth would you do that?
It sounds risky, right?
Historically speaking, alienated elites are exactly the people who fund rebellions, hire mercenaries, and overthrow governors.
If you alienate the powerful, you lose your province.
You would think so, but the mandate paints a precise, devastating psychological portrait of the elite class.
What does it say about them?
It describes them as heavy in easy times, resentful of fair treatment, and painfully slow to be grateful.
So they are basically unmanageable.
They are high maintenance, fair weather friends.
They view every concession you make as their inherent right and every boundary you set as an intolerable insult.
A bottomless pit of demands.
Exactly.
The common folk, on the other hand, are the actual structural pillar of religion and defense.
They hold the whole thing up.
They do.
The mandate explicitly states that the discontent of the common folk cancels out the contentment of the elite, while the discontent of the elite is easily absorbed and neutralized within the broad contentment of the common folk.
Because there are just so many more of them.
Yes, the center of gravity for a truly just state must always be the many, never the few.
How is this different from ordinary governance advice just dressed up in religious vocabulary?
I see where you're going with this.
Right, because
Machiavelli would also tell a ruler to keep the masses happy.
Yes, he would.
He argues that a prince must avoid being hated by the people to ensure a stable throne because a fortress cannot save a ruler who is hated by his subjects.
True.
Isn't this just pragmatic politics?
Keep the masses fed so they don't drag you into the street.
It is a vital challenge, and it is dangerously easy to misread this text as pure pragmatism.
It sounds very pragmatic.
It does.
And to steelman your point, yes, keeping the masses satisfied is undeniably the best way to prevent a violent revolt.
But the ultimate measure here, the finish line, is completely different.
Different how?
The goal of this mandate is not a stable throne.
It's not.
No.
A ruler could achieve a stable throne through brutal
surveillance, fear, and state sponsored terror.
The goal here is a clean account before God.
A clean account.
And we know for a fact this is the case because of the doctrine of concealment that immediately follows.
Okay, wait.
Which completely dismantles any possibility of a pragmatic security state.
The doctrine of concealment, I need you to unpack that.
How does concealment dismantle a security state?
Think about what a pragmatic Machiavellian security state actually does.
It gathers intel.
It hunts for hitting faults.
It relies on a vast network of informants, blackmail, wiretaps, and exposing the private sins of its citizens to maintain maximum leverage and control over the populace.
The more you know, the more power you have.
Exactly.
The Imam commands the exact radical opposite.
What does he command?
He tells the governor to keep informants the furthest away from him and to view them
members of society.
The most despised.
Yes.
The ruler is ordered to aggressively veil the hidden faults of others so that God will veil his own faults.
But that completely subverts the entire purpose of an intelligence apparatus.
Yes, it does.
An intelligence agency exists solely to uncover what is hidden.
That's its only job.
But here, the ruler is being told that his duty is only to correct what has become public and plain.
Exactly.
The hidden faults, the private whispers, the closed door meeting.
the personal failings, belong entirely to God's jurisdiction, not the states.
Exactly.
A government that makes it its primary business to expose private failings does not become more just.
No, it becomes a nightmare.
It becomes a paranoid machine of suspicion.
The mandate warns that a slanderer or an informant is fundamentally A deceiver, even if they appear to be giving sincere advice to protect the state.
Because their method is inherently toxic.
The spiritual reciprocity here is absolute.
The concealment you extend to your subjects in this world is the exact measure of concealment.
God will extend to your own glaring faults in the next.
That is a massive tradeoff.
It is.
This proves beyond a shadow of a doubt that the goal is a clean spiritual account, not just political survival.
Right, because if it were just survival.
A pragmatic survivor would keep the informants close.
A spiritually accountable leader banishes them.
It requires an almost unimaginable amount of trust to govern a volatile province without leaning on a network of informants.
It's an incredible leap of faith.
It means accepting A terrifying degree of vulnerability.
You are consciously choosing to be blind to certain things on purpose.
You are.
Which makes who you actually let into your room incredibly important.
And that leads directly to the theology of hiring.
The theology of hiring.
I like that phrase.
The mandate doesn't just give a limp of good resume qualities.
It explicitly forbids the hiring of misers, cowards, and greedy men into your inner circle.
Okay, those seem like bad traits.
But it does not just list them as having annoying personality traits.
It diagnoses all three of them as suffering from the exact
same underlying spiritual disease.
Which is what?
do a miser, a coward, and a greedy man have in common?
A catastrophically bad opinion of God.
Really.
Let's break it down.
Think of the miser.
The miser refuses to spend fearing poverty because he fundamentally believes God's provision is scarce and unreliable.
He doesn't trust that there will be enough.
Right.
Now think of the coward.
The coward fears defeat and flees from duty, believing God's protection is weak or non-existent.
He doesn't trust he'll be saved.
The greedy man.
He hoards wealth obsessively, believing God is not generous enough to sustain him without his own frantic hoarding.
So all three are rooted in a lack of trust.
Exactly.
If you surround yourself with these men, their internal spiritual scarcity will rapidly infect your public policy.
The policy just becomes a projection of the minister's internal theology.
Completely.
If your cabinet believes in a cold, stingy universe,
They will inevitably create a cold, stingy administration.
Because that's all they know how to bill.
If you have a miser managing your infrastructure, he will tell you not to fund public works because, well, we might need the money later.
He'll hoard the budget.
If you have a coward advising your foreign policy, he will tell you to compromise the state's integrity
and capitulate to enemies out of sheer panic.
He'll surrender at the first sign of trouble.
And if a greedy man manages your revenue, he will dress up extortion and theft as lawful taxation.
He absolutely will.
Are there any absolute bans on who can be hired regardless of their personality?
Yes.
The harshest, most unbending ban in the entire letter is on ministers who served evil rulers before you arrived.
The holdovers.
The mandate is uncompromising here, says
directly to the governor.
Do not let such men into your inner circle under any circumstances.
Under any circumstances.
None.
They are helpers of sinners and brothers of tyrants.
I have to push back hard on this one.
Go ahead.
What if they are incredibly competent?
It's a common argument.
Running a massive bureaucracy like Egypt's requires deep institutional knowledge.
A former minister knows how the grain silos work, how the tax routes are mapped, where the supply chain bottlenecks are.
They know where the bodies are buried.
Exactly.
If you fire the entire middle and upper management just because they worked for the last guy, you are going to plunge the province into administrative chaos.
It seems like a huge unforced error.
Isn't it a massive risk to discard that level of competence?
It seems like managerial suicide, doesn't it?
Does.
But the mandate argues that their technical competence is entirely irrelevant because their fundamental formation is corrupted.
Their formation.
Yes, they have been shaped by the machinery of oppression.
Their muscle memory is injustice.
It's baked into how they operate.
Their default reflex when faced with a problem is to squeeze
is the weak.
The imam insists that you can always find substitutes of equal or greater intellectual ability who carry none of that inherited guilt and none of those toxic reflexes.
So there's always someone else who can do the job.
Always.
And crucially, he argues that those untainted men will cost you far less in the long run.
Cost less how?
Both materially in terms of corruption and spiritually in terms of your own complicity in their inevitable abuses.
Okay, so you have purged your cabinet of the cowards, the misers and the whole
from the previous tyrannical regime.
Your team is clean.
Your inner circle is solid.
But now you have to actually govern the physical dirt of the province.
The actual land.
Right.
Let's shift our focus to the Earth itself and the revenue it generates.
Every state, no matter how spiritually grounded, requires capital to function.
You can't run a state on just good intentions.
Exactly.
You have to pay the scribes, you have to pave the roads, you have to maintain the border defenses.
Yes, and the mandate outlines 4 specific, highly practical tasks for the governor regarding the physical province.
What are they?
Gather its revenues, fight its enemies, seek the welfare of its people, and prosper its land.
Okay, those sound standard.
They are.
Now, any standard imperial manual from
from Rome to the modern era would fiercely prioritize the first two taxes and war.
Get the money, fight the wars.
Extract the wealth, kill the threats.
But the imam systematically brackets gathering revenue and fighting enemies and strictly subordinates both of them to the welfare of the people and the prospering of the land.
So he is completely inverting the extractive model of rule.
Completely upside down.
The state does not exist to drain the province like a battery for the benefit of the capital.
No.
The wealth of a country is not the gold sitting in the public treasury.
Precisely.
The wealth of a country is simply the wealth of its people held in a slower, more deliberate form.
A slower form.
I like that.
If you drain the people dry to fill the public treasury, you're behaving like a delusional sailor who bails water from one end of a sinking boat into the other and proudly calls it progress.
You're just moving the disaster around.
This brings us back to the core spine of our discussion, which must be repeated verbatim as
from the spiritual to the material.
Let's hear it.
A man who cannot govern his own soul cannot justly govern a province.
Because if his soul is governed by greed, he will view the land merely as an inert resource to be mined.
A battery to be drained.
Rather than a living, breathing system to be nurtured.
And the mandate puts this philosophy into a stark, undeniable economic formula.
An economic formula?
It commands the governor to let his concern for the cultivation of the land
vastly outweigh his concern for collecting the tax.
Vastly outweigh.
Why?
Because, as the text states plainly, no tax will be gathered where there is no cultivation.
Obviously, you can't tax a barren field.
The state is forced to serve the people furthest from its halls of power, the people actually working the soil.
Cultivation must sit above extraction.
This is our second governing analogy, isn't it?
Yes, it is.
The gardener who commands an army.
Yes.
A predatory ruler prioritizes the tribute tax above all else, alongside rapid military expansion.
Right, just grab the money and the land.
But if you read the specific charges in the Imam's order, you are looking at the job description of a master gardener who just happens to command an army.
Think about how a gardener views dirt.
It's his lifeblood.
He doesn't extract from it.
He aerates it.
He waters it.
He protects it from pests, knowing that the fruit is a byproduct of healthy soil.
It takes patience.
In this framework, taxes and war are not ends in themselves.
They are only necessary instruments for making the land thrive.
Only instruments.
If the people complain of a heavy burden or a sudden blight on their crops or a lack of rain or their irrigation canals being disrupted,
The governor is ordered to immediately lighten what they owe.
And this isn't just framed as an act of pity or charity, is it?
Not at all.
It's framed as a rigorous strategic investment.
Exactly.
The mandate frames it as a direct investment that will yield massive returns in the future prosperity of the land.
You're investing in the soil.
A prosperous, thriving land can bear future burdens if an emergency arises.
An impoverished, exhausted land collapses under the lightest touch of taxation.
It shatters.
The devastation of the land always, without exception, begins in the souls of the governors.
I want to trace that causality.
It's A fascinating link.
How does the text connect the invisible soul of a governor in a palace
to ruin crops in a field hundreds of miles away.
It draws a direct, unbroken line.
It states that the devastation of the land comes exclusively from the destitution of its inhabitants.
And the destitution of the inhabitants comes about only when the frantic desire to amass wealth rules the souls of the governors.
It is a fatal chain reaction.
Greed is defined here not just as wanting more, but as severe spiritual short-sightedness.
A ruler aggressively
squeezes the land tax out of a struggling populace only when he severely doubts what endures and forgets that he will inevitably be judged.
He's panic courting.
If he truly deeply remembered his mortality, he would never trade eternal spiritual ruin for a temporary spike in revenue.
That brings us to the actual mechanics of society.
The mandate doesn't just offer broad economic philosophy or poetic metaphors.
No, it gets very granular.
It details the specific pillars of the state.
How do you actually organize a society under this vision?
The specific classes that make up the great wheel of society.
Who are they?
You have the soldiers, the judges, the scribes, the merchants, and the destitute.
Okay, five classes.
And it makes a profound theological claim about all these classes.
God has assigned each its due as a binding covenant.
Binding covenant.
The distribution of rights across these groups is not a clever policy the governor invents.
It is a sacred trust he is bound to protect.
Okay, I have to pose a.
Rigorous challenge here.
Go for it.
Can a state actually function this way in the real world?
That is the big question.
He wants soldiers to be treated with the affection of parents for their children.
He wants judges to be paid an absolute fortune so they are completely independent.
He wants the open market to be generally trusted, but hoarders to be violently punished.
Yes, he does.
And on top of all that, he wants the ruler to purposefully surround himself with people who criticize him to his face.
All true.
It sounds like an administrative fancy.
That sounds impossible.
It sounds like a utopian blueprint that would collapse the moment a real crisis hit.
It is a massive challenge to the purely pragmatic, cynical
mind.
But let's look at the brilliant underlying mechanism that is applied uniformly across every single pillar you just mentioned.
What's the mechanism?
It is a two-part mechanism, generous provision and close watching.
Provision and watching.
Let's take the judges and the scribes.
You pay the judge and the scribes so much, you flood them with so much provision, that basic human need cannot possibly tempt them to take a bribe.
So you remove the economic incentive to cheat.
And simultaneously you watch them so closely that the
opportunity for corruption cannot tempt them either.
I see it now.
I have to concede this point.
It's pretty elegant, isn't it?
It's not naive at all.
It refuses the utopian fantasy that good character alone will survive starvation and temptation, and it equally refuses the cynics fantasy that surveillance and fear alone create an honest society.
Exactly.
It's a perfectly balanced psychological system.
You saturate their needs so they have no excuse, and you watch their actions so they have no cover.
Exactly.
the environment to make it easier to be honest than to be corrupt.
It's behavioral design.
Think about the vulnerability of a judge.
If a judge is poor, he can be bought by the wealthy merchants.
Easily.
If a judge is exposed and unprotected, he can be frightened and intimidated by the powerful military elite.
They'll just threaten his family.
The mandate solves both of these vulnerabilities by commanding the governor to pay the judge generously and to grant him a rank of nearness to the governor himself so that the judge is
safe, shielded, and untouchable by anyone else in the state.
He's bulletproof.
But simultaneously, the governor must quietly and relentlessly watch their affairs through trusted observers.
So there's the accountability.
And if an officer betrays that sacred trust, the punishment is swift, severe, and highly public because showing mercy to the citizens demands absolute severity toward the officer who preys on them.
The mechanism is highly practical, but it requires a governor who is constantly, deeply attentive.
You can't just set it
and forget it.
The system doesn't run on autopilot.
Which brings us to our third analogy, the hub and the axle.
Yes, visualize society as a massive wooden wheel.
Like a wagon wheel.
The various classes we just discussed, the soldiers, the scribes, the merchants, the judges, are the spokes radiating outward.
Okay.
The governor himself is the central hub.
But think about the engineering of a wheel.
The hub turns nothing.
It moves nowhere unless it stays firmly joined to the unseen axle.
It just sits there.
In this analogy, the axle is the real God himself.
If the hub disconnects from the axle, what happens?
The friction builds uncontrollably, the wheel shatters, the cart flips, and the entire society crashes.
The whole thing just breaks down.
The administrative machine, no matter how well funded, only functions if the ruler remains spiritually grounded to the center.
And part of maintaining that grounding, preventing that
destructive friction involves who the ruler deliberately allows to speak.
Communication is key.
We talked earlier about keeping informants far away, but who is brought close?
Who gets the seat next to the governor?
The absolute highest rank in the ruler's inner circle is given to the bitter truth teller.
The bitter truth teller.
The imam commands the governor to elevate the man who most readily speaks the bitter truth and who gives the absolute least encouragement in whatever the governor does that God dislikes.
So the most valuable person in the room, the highest paid, most respected advisor, is the one who consistently makes the ruler the most uncomfortable.
Precise.
That goes against every
ego impulse.
Because a ruler surrounded exclusively by applause rapidly loses the ability to hear reality.
They get high on their own supply.
Excessive praise breeds deep conceit.
The truth teller is the literal anchor that prevents the hub from spinning off the axle.
The text also emphasizes A radical form of accessibility, particularly for the destitute.
How does this play out physically?
This is perhaps one of the most moving and demanding parts of the entire mandate.
How so?
The lowest class,
no resources, the disabled, the afflicted, the orphans, they are the sharpest, truest test of a society's justice.
The canary in the coal mine.
Why?
Because a ruler gains absolutely zero political capital by helping them.
They don't have lobbyists.
They cannot fund his campaigns, they cannot fight in his armies, and they cannot write poems praising his name.
There's no ROI on them in a purely political sense.
None.
Yet the Imam commands the governor to assign them a fixed, non-negotiable share
from the public treasury, explicitly noting that those furthest away from the capital have the exact same right as those living next door to the palace.
Distance from power should not equal distance from provision.
Exactly.
But how does the governor actually interact with them?
To ensure this isn't just a bureaucratic exercise, the ruler must physically sit with the destitute in an assembly entirely stripped of guards.
Stripped of guards.
Pause and picture that.
It's hard to imagine today.
For a provincial governor in a time of severe unrest, surrounded by
political enemies, to sit in a room full of desperate people without his armed security detail, that is intense physical vulnerability.
It's terrifying.
It goes against every single instinct of self-preservation a leader has.
The mandate demands it so that the weak may speak without inhibition.
The apparatus of protection is always simultaneously an apparatus of insulation.
It keeps people out.
Think about the physical space of power.
If A destitute, trembling citizen has to pass through massive iron gates, walk past rows of heavily armed soldiers, and stand before a raised throne just to voice a grievance about their stolen land, they will remain silent.
Of course they will.
The physical intimidation will choke the words in their throat.
It's designed to do exactly that.
The ruler must personally tear down the physical walls of intimidation.
The mandate states clearly, a nation where the rights of the weak cannot be rested without fear from the strong will never, ever be blessed.
It forces the ruler to experience the visceral reality of his people directly.
You can't hide from it.
If you wall yourself off behind security details and sycophants, you lose awareness of what your province actually feels like.
It just becomes numbers on a page.
The beautiful begins to appear ugly, the small appears great, and you end up governing
hallucination, a spreadsheet, rather than a living, breathing province.
This philosophy of radical accessibility even extends to how the ruler leads the community in worship.
Even in worship.
The Imam shares a stunning instruction he learned directly from the Prophet.
Peace and blessings of Allah be upon him and his family.
When leading communal prayer, the ruler must deliberately pace the entire service to the weakest, frailest person in the row.
Pace it to the weakest.
Even the rhythm of the sacred, the speed of the prayer, is dictated by the most vulnerable member of society, not the strongest.
That is profound.
It really is.
The state's mudget, the economy's taxes, even the communal prayers pacing everything
fundamentally calibrated not by the strongest elites, but by the weakest citizens.
It is a complete inversion of how power usually organizes space and time.
Which brings us to the final beat, the gravest stakes of all.
The international stage.
How does a ruler operating under this vision deal with external enemies, with treaties, and with the shedding of blood?
The mandate shifts from the internal mechanics of the province to ultimate
Eternal accountability.
In the realm of foreign policy, expediency is usually the undisputed king.
Always.
Treaties are broken the exact moment they are no longer strategically advantageous.
The imam explicitly and violently forbids this.
He does.
He tells the governor to make peace if God's pleasure lies in it, as peace brings essential rest to the soldiers and vital security to the lands.
Peace is good.
But if a pledge is made or a covenant of protection is granted to an enemy, the governor must make his very life a physical
shield for that promise.
Even if dealing with an enemy who might be treacherous.
Yes.
An enemy who might use the peace treaty to rearm.
Even then.
The mandate advises staying highly on guard, but it insists that the pledge itself must be kept with absolute unwavering trustworthiness.
So you can't strike first if you sign a treaty.
And the reasoning is deeply theological, not tactical.
The sanctity of the promise doesn't come from the enemy's trustworthiness.
It is sacred because God has made his pledge
a sanctuary.
So the promise belongs to God, not the enemy.
Exactly.
To break a treaty is to desecrate what belongs to God.
Even if breaking the treaty would provide a massive, immediate strategic advantage for your armies, it is forbidden because it invites an eternal reckoning that no temporary military advantage can possibly survive.
It completely removes the classic loophole of state interest.
You can't use that excuse.
You cannot commit treachery and claim it was for the good of the province.
The end does not justify.
Exactly.
And this absolute moral boundary is drawn even stricter when it comes to human life.
Bloodshed.
The absolute warning on blood is unequivocal.
Never shed blood unlawfully to secure a throne.
The tyrant's ultimate oldest tool is violence.
It's the shortcut to stability.
The idea that a little targeted killing, a few strategic assassinations can stabilize a regime is ancient.
It's the cost of doing business in a brutal world.
The imam dismantles that horrific justification completely.
He tears it apart.
Unlawful bloodshed does not strengthen authority.
It triggers a divine countdown to its absolute destruction.
A divine countdown.
Power that rests on spilled blood is a catastrophically bad bargain.
God begins the judgment of the worlds with the blood that has been shed.
That is heavy.
The imam binds the governor personally, stating he will have absolutely no excuse before God if he kills anyone deliberately and unlawfully.
After laying out this massive, sweeping framework troop commands, clerk salaries, punishing hoarders in the market, international treaties, the architecture of justice,
It is fascinating where the letter finally ends.
It really is.
It returns entirely to the inner ground.
It beautifully closes the circle.
It does.
After all the external machinery of the state has been calibrated, the imam tells the governor that he will never master his temper, his hand, or his tongue unless he increases his remembrance of his return to his Lord.
Everything, absolutely everything we've discussed hinges on that single memory.
Just that one memory.
The mercy for the destitute, the open door without guards, the kept pledge with a
treacherous enemy, the unspilled blood.
It all flows from a man keeping alive in himself the burning memory that he will die, his body will fail, and he will go back to God to account for every single decision.
As a later poet would say, the crown is just a hat that lets the rein in if the head beneath it is hollow.
He signs off the longest letter of his life,
with a simple prayer that they might both die well, seeking a martyr's death.
A beautiful ending.
The letter that opened by refusing to let him govern Egypt before he had learned to govern himself closes by handing him nothing at all except that piercing memory.
A man who cannot govern his own soul cannot justly govern a province.
It is a devastatingly complete vision.
Completely holistic.
It leaves absolutely no room for the modern division of life into the secular and the sacred.
It demands total integration.
And so we turn this directly to you listening.
Yeah, think about it.
Think about the spheres of authority in your own life.
You might not be governing Egypt, but where are you signing the orders?
We all have some jurisdiction.
Consider one promise you have made or one small power you hold over someone else, an employee, a child, a student, a neighbor.
How are you using it?
How should the private, quiet remembrance of your ultimate return to God reshape the way you wield that exact power this week?